today on the matt welsh show the
left-wing media is hunting down and
combating misinformation quote-unquote
about the election the only problem is
that much of what they call
misinformation is actually completely
true
small little detail there plus five
headlines including the cdc's new
thanksgiving guidelines which i will
be sure personally to completely ignore
and i would urge you to do the same and
in our daily cancellation i will have to
cancel the ap
i think again the second time for coming
up with a whole new set of words that
are
uh now offensive according to them all
of that
on the way but first quick message from
our good friends
over at lightstream you know it's uh
it's
most people have a balance on their
credit cards with a high interest rate
and it's much higher than they would
prefer it's much higher than they have
to be paying
you can refinance your high interest
credit card balance and save with a
credit card consolidation loan
from light stream now the rates here
start at 5.95
apr with auto pay and if you have
excellent credit the rate is fixed so
you know that you got that confidence
and and
and that uh peace of mind to know that
it's not gonna go up over the life of
the loan
plus there are no additional fees you
have to worry about you can get a loan
from
if you want five thousand dollars up to
a hundred thousand dollars
you can even get your money as soon as
the day you apply
uh you know i've i've seen with many
people how they have debt
we all have debt for some people it
prevents them from
moving on with their lives moving
forward in their careers you know having
that financial stability that they
should have
uh and that's why my listeners can save
even more with an additional interest
rate discount the only way to get this
discount
is to go to lightstream.com walsh
that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com walsh subject to credit approval
rates range from 5.95 percent to 19.99
apr and include 0.5 auto pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply
and offers are subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.com
walsh for more information you know
we've heard
quite a lot over the last four years
about uh
quote unquote misinformation and now as
trump
challenges the ostensible results of the
election
this campaign by the media to combat
what they call misinformation has gone
into overdrive
everywhere they look now they're finding
this misinformation
some of the headlines just over the last
few hours uh quote
the misinformation media machine
amplifying trump's election lies
election misinformation continues
staying up on youtube
misinformation channels claim biden is
no longer president-elect
that's not true internet sleuths use
misinformation in an attempt to prove
dead people voted in michigan and on and
on now you'll notice of course that the
word misinformation
is only ever used to apply to
conservatives and conservative outlets
and i don't think i'm exaggerating her
i'm not aware of a single case ever of
the mainstream media
labeling a leftist claim as
misinformation
and that's not because leftists never
engage in it we'll have more on that in
just a minute
kevin roose of the the new york times is
on the misinformation beat
he tweeted this out uh yesterday he said
facebook is absolutely teeming with
right-wing misinformation right now
these are all among the 10 most engaged
urls on the platform over the last 24
hours
then he provides screenshots of four
misinformation articles
one of them written full disclosure by
the daily wire the headlines are these
are the headlines these are the
misinformation headlines okay listen to
these
republican in michigan goes from loser
to winner after technical glitch
fixed officials urge confidence in
system
michigan legislature holds rare
emergency session to investigate
irregularities
attorney general william barr authorizes
doj to look into voting irregularities
and perdue loffler call on georgia
secretary of state to resign
over election those are the
misinformation headlines
the problem with calling them
misinformation of course is that
they all happen to be true the
misinformation here is in labeling them
misinformation
now after a bunch of people pointed this
out ruse followed it up with this he
said
for the conservatives who are mad about
this yes it is possible for a story to
be factually accurate
and for it to be part of a
misinformation campaign
aimed at undermining confidence in the
election okay so do you understand that
a story can be factually accurate and
also be
misinformation factually accurate
misinformation that's what we're dealing
with now then he starts scrambling to
make his position
seem coherent because of course it's
totally incoherent finally he settles on
this he says
we need a better word than
misinformation to distinguish between
totally false stories and true stories
that are published in service of an
attempt to mislead people
but nobody who studies this stuff is
confused by what's happening okay true
stories
that are published in the service of an
attempt to mislead people
do you mean like i don't know this
segment that aired on abc news
suggesting that the defense secretary
getting fired might mean that trump is
on the verge of staging a military coup
listen to this well martha you've
covered washington you've covered the
pentagon for years have you ever seen an
interim period like this a defense
secretary out three more top pentagon
officials tonight and
if this is unsettling for folks at home
what do your sources tell you tonight is
there any concern that this could put
national security at risk
you know david no one has seen anything
like this there
is concern about what this means is the
president planning a military operation
or the use of federal troops which esper
opposed
even mitch mcconnell praised esper today
and republican john cornyn a member of
the senate gop leadership said of
trump's decision to fire
esper i don't think it helps him
and i don't think it helps the country
now the insinuation that trump is about
to declare himself
military dictator of the country seems
an awful lot to me
like misinformation and so does it so
does this from bloomberg
published yesterday it says for perhaps
the first time in american history
a coordinated effort to taint or
overturn a presidential election
may be underway yes bloomberg has pulled
out the flashy thing from men in black
and they're attempting now to wipe out
our memory of the last four years
so has cnn uh here's a segment they
aired just this morning
when it comes to claims about mass voter
fraud let's be clear
trump supporters you're being lied to
donald trump has a history of lying
loudly turning baseless accusations into
play to the base articles of faith
now the goal is often to create a fake
scandal to distract from a real one but
when the accusation is
actually investigated by republicans in
congress or the trump justice department
it comes up empty because there was
never anything there
okay fake scandals that fall apart
upon further investigation i can
think of quite a few of those personally
such as for example
pretty much every single trump scandal
over the last four years
but the media will never call their own
misinformation
misinformation that's never going to
happen so what do they really mean
when they use the term well i think that
kevin roose made it clear
being for a moment more honest than he
meant to be
to the media and also to the big tech
companies like facebook and twitter
a fact can still be misinformation
[Music]
even if it's a fact it can still be
misinformation if it's inconvenient
or offensive to some favored group of
people anyway
or if it might lead people to a
conclusion
at which our overlords and truth
ministers do not want us to arrive
and often the forbidden conclusion is
the right conclusion but even if it
isn't
i mean even if some set of true facts
may really be interpreted by some group
of people in the wrong way
set them down the wrong path that's no
excuse to censor the facts
or to mislabel them as false when they
aren't
people don't need to be protected in
this way an important part of being an
adult and an american in a free country
in the information age
is to pursue facts and form conclusions
using your own discernment
we don't need daddy cnn or mommy
facebook to hold our hands and
guide us this way or that besides if you
want to talk about
cherry-picked facts half-truths
out-of-context
tidbits being used in service of an
attempt to mislead as
the new york times says i can think of
no better example of that in modern
times than what we've witnessed over the
past five or six months in cities across
the country police shootings
caught on tape posted online without
context or with dishonestly framed
context
and spread by the media in order to
convince people that racist cops are
prowling the streets
murdering innocent minorities at will
now there is an example of how a reality
the reality that that so-and-so was shot
by the cops can be presented in such a
way as to cause people to form
conclusions
that are wildly off-base and dangerous
and destructive but even then
i wouldn't be in favor of censorship to
solve the problem
instead people who know the truth have
to stand up
speak it and battle the lies head on
that's the only way to deal with it
the left relies on on forms of
censorship and by the way
a major media outlet baselessly labeling
a truthful thing as
misinformation is a form of censorship
let's be clear about that
especially because they know that big
tech's going to take that and run with
it but they rely on these strategies
because
they don't have the truth on their side
they cannot meet you out on the
battlefield of ideas
and present their side that way they can
only shout you down
shut you down shut you up label you
maybe throw a molotov cocktail through
your window
for good measure these are the weapons
of liars and con
artists con artists these are their
tactics
and we should be sure not to fall for it
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i can tell you with everything
going on right now home school
has never seen more appealing to people
than it does
at the moment and that's and that's true
if you look at the statistics people are
flocking to homeschool
and we've been a homeschool family um
ever since our kids were school-aged
and here's what i can tell you uh
parents if you homeschool or if you want
to homeschool
if you're thinking about it i know it
can be kind of overwhelming just to just
to consider all the work and
responsibilities are going to be on your
shoulders you've got your kid's entire
education right that seems like it's up
to you
and for the parents with kids in school
if you've avoided the need to pull your
student out of the public school system
because it just seems too daunting to
homeschool them yourself which i know
there are a lot of parents in that
category i talk to them all the time
well no matter no matter your situation
homeschool magnet
is for a parent just like you are
guaranteed homeschool magnet
supports homeschooling families by
providing students with instruction from
world-class credentialed teachers
in a remote classroom with their peers
now parents can choose the best teachers
for each student based on
the values and teaching approach to
ensure that every child is receiving
exactly the education that they desire
that's what i like about homeschool
magnet is that it's putting the power
into your hands as a parent that's what
homeschooling is supposed to all be
about right
this puts you as the parent in full
control of your child's education
without the daily responsibilities of
lesson planning pre-learning teaching
tutoring grading
and all that kind of stuff each student
will receive instruction in the four
core subject areas of math
english language
science and social studies you know
other online schools exist
but homeschool magnet is unique because
even though homeschool magnet includes a
robust online learning environment each
student works from real physical
learning materials guided by video
instruction from their teachers
this approach is uh similar to most
remote college learning formats
and will help prepare students for
secondary school every student has daily
access to their teachers
who know their learning needs and can
help with instruction and tutoring
homeschool magnet even gives your
students the opportunity to join group
video tutoring calls homeroom style
group video calls for fun and
socialization
so you're getting all of that with
homeschool magnet homeschool magnet
is only a fraction of the cost of
private schools and the 30-day
money-back guarantee
upon enrollment means this choice is
risk-free plus
enrollment intuition or on a per
semester basis so you're only committing
for a short period of time
giving you even more flexibility and
control to shape your child's education
and this is this is what it's all about
it's all about giving you control over
your child's education so to learn more
about homeschool magnet student
experience go to homeschoolmagnet.com
and join the growing wait list and if
you're an interested teacher who wants
to
have more freedom in your teaching
career homeschool magnet may be perfect
for you as well
we're recruiting new teachers right now
so visit homeschoolmagnet.com
to learn more and apply all right well
the cdc
has uh released its thanksgiving
guidelines
i will be disregarding all of their
thanksgiving guidelines just as i've
disregarded
everything else they've said um but just
for fun
here they are from fox 5 and y here are
the guidelines
i'll read a few of these to you in case
in case you're wondering in case you in
case you want to
get the cdc's approval like you're
planning your thanksgiving
dinner and celebration and you're
thinking what does a cdc think about
this
here's what they say limiting the number
of attendees as much as possible and
allowing people from home
from different households to social
distance at all at all times is also
encouraged
hosting the gathering outdoors rather
than indoors as much as possible and
requiring guests to wear
masks when they aren't eating or
drinking is also encouraged
if you're hosting an indoor gathering
the cdc says to increase ventilation as
much as possible
by opening windows and doors thanks for
that recommendation cds i i i never
would have thought to open my windows if
it's a little stuffy inside
i needed the cdc to tell me that when it
comes to food and drinks the cdc says
hosts should encourage guests to bring
food for themselves and members of their
household
and to avoid potluck style gatherings
okay so you're all bringing your own
meal and you're just sitting
down uh with glass partitions
with masks on lift the mask up
stuff the the turkey wing in if you're
preparing or serving food for guests
that don't live in your household you
should wear a mask
guests are encouraged to have a plan for
storing their mask while eating and
drinking
um as always everyone is asked to wash
their hands with hope
soap and water for 20 seconds
again i needed the cdc to tell me that i
would never have thought
to wash my hands with soap and water
usually i use
um ginger ale to wash my hands
and so uh every time every time i see
this reminder from the cdc use soap and
water i think
oh yeah i forgot the second iteration of
cdc thanksgiving guidance also includes
recommendations for safe travel and
overnight stays
um and uh blah blah blah on and on
yeah this is this is something i just
will not be
paying attention to whatsoever um
and yet again th this is this is
the cdc now at least at least it's the
cdc here
it's a lot worse than like in a place
like california where you've got the
health department
taking all of these guidelines and
actually
making it a a matter of law even though
of course the
department of health doesn't have the
authority to just create laws
but um they're trying to do it and
they're trying to use the force of law
to force you to do it so at least with
the cdc it's just a guideline
which we don't have to listen to and um
and i won't you know this is this is one
of the worst things
to come of the covid hysteria is just
the the paranoia and suspicion that
we're supposed to have
even towards our own families
like if you're if your aunt comes to
your thanksgiving
and she brought her green bean casserole
do you know you don't eat that it might
be infected with coven
number two um this from the daily wire
says the fallout from this summer's
riots which saw
businesses large and small looted and
burned to the ground continues to be
seen
as a new report for the new york times
shines a light on the insurance woes
faced by those whose livelihoods were
destroyed in the name of racial justice
it says the outlet reported while large
chains like walmart and best buy have
excellent insurance
many small businesses that have been
burned down since the riots lack similar
coverage and for them
there is no easy way to replace all that
they lost in kenosha
more than 35 small businesses were
completely destroyed and around 80 have
been damaged according to the city's
business association
almost all are locally owned and many
are underinsured or struggling to manage
now and the the report goes on with the
daily wire you can read it there but
i wanted to highlight that because this
is something you heard from the rioters
and from blm the the excuse they gave
is that uh including that clip we played
a few times of the blm activist i think
she was in chicago
saying that looting is a form of
reparations and encouraging people to do
it and saying oh the businesses all have
insurance so you just take what you want
now these are people who don't
understand how insurance works it's not
just you
you have insurance so you can you can
take whatever you want and magically
like you you could burn down their
business and because you have insurance
it will
magically you know regenerate on its own
like the wolverine and x-men or
something as regeneration power suggests
you
steal whatever you want you can steal
the tv and then the tv will will
re-materialize in its place
um that seems to be what they think but
that's not how insurance works
and also as it turns out of course a lot
of these businesses
don't have insurance or underinsured
and you know even even if they even if
they do have insurance that can cover
all of it of course
just this should go without saying that
doesn't
mean you can just go and take whatever
you want
like if if i'm if i'm sure that you have
really great car insurance
that doesn't mean i can just ram into
you on the highway and say well you got
car insurance what do you
what are you whining about you got car
insurance
number three this is a tough time for
the media because they can't quite
decide if if now you know now that
they've declared buy in the winner
they can't quite decide if they should
just pretend that covet has gone away
and been cured or if they should double
down on the fear porn
in hopes that biden will put us into a
full lockdown again
mask mandates and everything else so
they're kind of trying to walk this high
wire
act of propaganda where they're they're
sort of doing both
and i feel for them because it's got to
be difficult to figure out exactly how
you want to lie to people but on the
fear porn side of things
there's this article from reuters
headline is
very scary headline listen to the
headline
one in five covet 19 patients develop
mental
illness within 90 days okay now
this makes it sound like covet is
causing some kind of neurological damage
making people go insane or something
when they have covet 19. that that's
what it sounds like when you see that
headline
and if you saw that headline you didn't
click on it you would just absorb that
impression that half-baked vague
impression
and bring it with you throughout your
your day and that's that's what you're
supposed to do that's the point
but then you click on and here's what it
says many cova 19 survivors are likely
to be at a greater risk of developing
mental illness
according to psychiatrists after a large
study found 20 of those infected with
the chronovirus
are diagnosed with a psychiatric
disorder within 90 days
what are the disorders though anxiety
depression and
insomnia were the most common uh
reported among recovered cova 19
patients in the study
anxiety depression and insomnia okay
so people with coronavirus a disease
that the media says
will kill them a disease that we're told
you know we had to shut down the country
for
um when they have it they feel anxious
and depressed wow amaze huge news
amazing put this in a headline you got
it it's incredible stuff
i can't believe that people who get sick
with a virus
that even donald trump calls the plague
which by the way i really wish you would
stop doing that
but crazy that the people with that
virus would have anxiety about it
totally unexpected hey you know i wonder
what kind of mental illness
have the lockdowns caused and the media
coverage
i bet there's a lot of anxiety and
depression out there from people who
never even got sick
now this is ridiculous but then you know
i i must admit
i say all this admittedly as someone who
holds an extremely
heterodox view about anxiety and
depression
um i don't really agree that either of
those things are mental illnesses to
begin with
like i said i know it's heretical these
days you're not allowed to say this
um i i actually think that anxiety in
particular
is a completely normal though not
enjoyable aspect of the human experience
even a defining aspect of the human
experience part of what makes us human
is that we can contemplate our own
existence
and feel despair or feel worried about
feel anxious
which doesn't mean that despair and
anxiety are good or should be welcomed
but it does mean that it's not a disease
it's not a disorder
it's not a medical issue and it's a
perfect example of why
oh they have to they have depression and
anxiety
there's a very a very discernible reason
for
that sort of called a mental illness is
absurd it's just
you're reacting in a pretty normal way
to your environment
now i think there are a lot of people
that have way too much anxiety about the
chronovirus because of all the fear porn
that the media puts out but still it's a
it's a normal and predictable reaction
to your environment
and in general even even without even
without coronavirus
the fact is that there's there's a lot
in the world that could make someone
feel despair make them feel anxious make
them feel anxiety
again not saying you should feel it not
saying if you do feel you should just
embrace it and live with it
um but it's not it's not disordered it's
not diseased
but of course what the what the
pharmaceutical industry has done is
they've just decided
they've taken these normal aspects of
the human experience
and they've drawn completely arbitrary
lines and said
um you know it's okay to feel this much
despair like here's the despair line
and you can feel despair up to that line
but if you feel it over that line
now it's a disease and we're going to
medicate it who
who says who where did you come up with
this who told you where the line is
all right um as we have covered leftists
have been busy making lists recently
lists of all the heretics who have
been insufficiently loyal to leftist
orthodoxy especially anyone who's
expressed support for trump
and they seem to have gotten on on the
list kick and are going wild with it
right now
uh here's a list that was on cnn
yesterday this woman whoever she is i'm
not sure who is
she has a list of gop senators who have
not congratulated joe biden
and it's it's like all of them except
for i guess mitt romney so it's pretty
much all that you
might be one or two others of
congratulated so i look at this and i
can pretty much guarantee you
that this lady has a similar list at her
house probably up on her fridge of every
acquaintance
who didn't wish her a happy birthday i'd
like to
see a segment on that subject maybe cnn
could do a segment
about all the people who didn't wish
this woman a happy birthday or maybe
extended family members who still
haven't sent her
a wedding gift you know even though her
wedding was three years ago
these list list makers they just they
can't help themselves
finally i want to play this for you uh
simply because it is to my mind the most
important piece of reporting
that msnbc has ever done
this was really hard-hitting stuff and i
just thought it was uh a really
really important piece of reporting here
it is take a look nbc's
has some new reporting on something that
we talked about at the top of the hour
how the trump administration is handling
the transition with the incoming biden
team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our intelligence community
uh ken what have you learned sir
oh sh
okay uh i think we lost i think we lost
ken for a sec
i think the explanation that he gave for
that is that he was having
technical difficulties and didn't
realize he was on camera
and so that's why that happened but the
way that i read it
at least what i would like to think is
that he got some
he's reacting to like some news via text
message
or maybe he was trying to order chicken
wings by doordash
but the place was outside of the the
delivery zone
and i admit i have reacted in a similar
way in
similar situations many many times just
not usually on on camera though that's
the only difference so
but that is maybe msnbc's best moment i
think
it's only right for us to take a moment
and recognize it all right we're going
to get to our daily cancellation
in just one second but first a word from
another one of our sponsors mac weldon
you know
it's it's important i think when you're
wearing clothes to be comfortable
and but at the same time you want to you
want to look like you care about
how you look my wife especially is
always telling me that
uh with without the normal routines of
going to the office having business
meetings and the like
men are wearing a lot of jeans soft knit
polos tees joggers
uh active shorts whatever men's basic
basics
whatever they are you need mac weldon
and they've got you covered with
unmatched comfort
and fit so you got and you got the style
comfort everything they've got men's
essentials like socks
shirts hoodies underwear polos active
shorts
mack weldon promises comfort and a
consistent fit plus there's the
versatility to it so you look great
you feel great from working out going
out going to work or on a date whatever
it is mac welding is for everyday life
uh whatever the situation whatever
situation arises you know you've got
mack weldon and there's technology too
they've got a wide range of customized
fabrics that can keep you
keep up with with you no matter what
your day looks like no matter what
you're doing
um and also you know i want to tell you
about weld and blue it's a totally free
loyalty program level one
gets you free shipping for life once you
reach level two by spending two hundred
dollars you get twenty percent off
every order for the next year that's
pretty incredible and there's and
you've always got the mac welding
guarantee they want you to be
comfortable so
if you don't like your first pair of
underwear you can keep it
and they'll still refund you you're not
gonna have to send back the underwear
which is good
um you keep the underwear but they're
gonna refund you no questions asked
uh but here's here's what i would tell
you that if you get mac welding you're
not gonna wanna send it back
and once you go with mac welding you
don't go back to something else for 20
off your first order visit macweldon.com
walsh and enter promo code walsh and
again it's macweldon.com
walls promo code walsh for 20 off mack
weldon
reinventing men's basics you know one
other note here
if you if you weren't already uh
disgusted by the legacy media
which probably you were but you should
be now the media has preemptively of
course called the election in favor of
joe biden and they're further
claiming that trump is undermining
elections by noggins and we talked about
all this earlier
with their misinformation claims but you
know they accuse others of
misinformation but
as usual it's projection just because
cnn and fox news declare something
doesn't make it true it means they're
pushing a narrative that benefits them
not only that but the media has already
shifted from demonizing president trump
and his supporters to flattering biden
and harris before they didn't take an
office
the dust hasn't settled yet on the
election and we're already reading
stories about joe's
rescue dogs and that's gonna be tough
for me if joe biden is president
i like to listen to stories about his
dogs for me especially that's gonna be a
difficult thing to deal with
jill's stunning wardrobe they're telling
us about look if you're sick of the
media feeding you the narrative
then replace your cable and your new
subscriptions with the daily wire we
have big plans for these next four years
and it all starts today uh candace owens
new york times best-selling author
and founder of the blex foundation we
made the big announcement last week
she's joining the daily wire we're all
excited about that we'll should be
launching a brand new show with us
early next year uh also we're gonna have
an entertainment channel
a new investigative journalism team
we're building partnerships with
like-minded content creators like
prageru
who by the end of the year their entire
show library will be available on
dailywire.com so just
yet another perk you get if you're a
dailywire.com member
we're going after the legacy media and
we're going to do it by building a huge
membership base of supporters just like
you
so right now just to show you we're
serious we're offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe members get our articles
ad-free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
exclusive readers past content all of
that for daily wire members if you're
considering an all-access membership you
also get to take part in our
live stream discussions with our hosts
and our amazing online community
you also get not one but two leftist
tiers tumblers with your membership as
well as
early and sometimes exclusive access to
new daily wire products so remember
that's 25 off all memberships with code
election over at dailywire.com
subscribe you can replace the legacy
media with the daily wire
you won't regret it i guarantee you all
right let's get to our daily
cancellation
now before we really get into it i have
to address something briefly from
yesterday's cancellation as you know i
was canceling a whole bunch of
states for their incorrect viewpoints
on what the best thanksgiving side
dishes are during that cancellation
spree
i did cancel alabama
for listing dressing as its favorite
side dish
i thought they meant salad dressing like
ranch or something i have since been
informed
that dressing in the south means
stuffing many in the audience are
demanding that i retract
my cancellation of alabama apologize to
alabama
for slandering them let me be very clear
about this i do not retract
i do not apologize it's not my fault
that you you people use the wrong word
to refer to stuffing
stuffing is stuffing so-called because
often you will stuff it into the cavity
of the turkey
i don't know who first came up with the
idea of stuffing chunks of bread into a
turkey's ass
but that's neither here nor there
dressing
makes no sense as a name for stuffing so
alabama is canceled
for using the wrong word to refer to it
i take no responsibility for this
i apologize to no one in fact i demand
that you all apologize to me
for making me feel stupid and
embarrassed when in fact i'm the one
who's using the proper names for things
you all should be ashamed how dare you
how dare alabama you're canceled again
now today for our daily cancellation
another spree
uh maybe spree is too aggressive and
intimidating of a term
maybe i'm not going on a cancellation
spree but rather daintily spreading the
cancellations around like a fairy
sprinkling
pixie dust i don't know however you'd
like to describe it i must cancel first
the associated press
for this tweet from their style book it
says do not use derogatory terms such as
insane crazy slash crazed nuts or
deranged
unless they're part of a quotation
that's essential to the story avoid
using mental health terms
to describe unrelated issues don't say
that an award show for example was
schizophrenic now they noticeably
do not rule out calling someone whacked
out
cuckoo for cocoa puffs one fry short of
a happy meal one can short of a six pack
one card short of a full deck
bonkers i still retain the right to use
all those terms then
and also all the other terms that the ap
has just outlined outlawed
i can use all that too but the situation
gets worse because this tweet was met
with
appropriate derision in mockery from a
lot of people
but the mockery was not as universal or
widespread as it should have been in
fact
lots of comments were agreeing and
adding to the insanity
excuse me that no insanity was the right
word i'll stick with that
um here are some of the comments okay
this these are from real people
thank you for this addicted is another
word casually thrown around which is
something
those of us in recovery often struggle
with someone else said
i would like to adjust and add calling
people wild
wouldn't be your best choice of words
this term can be slash has been used to
oppress
poc indigenous people and their cultures
use wisely someone else explains that
bonkers
is not an acceptable replacement term
she says bananas yes
bonkers no bonkers is thought to stem
from terms related to being hit on the
head
etc and still means crazy mad etc
bananas is just a way of saying
something is silly
she then suggests wild also has a choice
um and someone else corrects her by
informing her that wild can be offensive
to native native tribes
as we just heard all of this is real by
the way these are not satire accounts
so let me add a couple of notes here
first of all
bananas is still offensive because it
brings to mind
the cartoons of people slipping on
banana peels
hitting their heads which also minimizes
and diminishes the suffering of head
injury patients
also bananas grow in tropical regions
often harvested by poor people and
minorities
this is their livelihood to suggest that
their livelihood is silly or a joke to
you
is extremely dehumanizing and offensive
to those poor tropical islanders who i'm
sure
have nothing better to do with their
time than troll twitter
looking for things to be offended by
really any synonym you might find for
crazy can be offensive any word at all
can be offensive
any object or thing or concept can be
offensive
i can walk outside right now pick up a
random like stick off the ground
and find a dozen reasons at least to be
offended by the stick
i can be offended by anything if i want
to be i once spent three hours offended
by a potato
just for fun so this is child's play to
me
and by the way the term child's play is
offensive because it suggests that only
children play games which can be
humiliating to gamers who don't like it
when you notice that they have no life
once you go down this road it never ends
the whole exercise is absurd the one guy
saying he doesn't like to hear the word
addicted used because he's an addict
what so you struggle with this issue
which means none of us are allowed to
even say the word in your presence
or you have mental health problems and
that means five dozen words have to be
ripped out of the dictionary so that
you never have to experience a moment of
discomfort by simply hearing a word that
vaguely
and jokingly refers to your condition
that's not how language works
that's not how communication works the
point of communication is to convey
meaning a person communicates
in order to take the thoughts that are
in his head and make them understandable
to his listener the point of
communication is not to avoid offense if
that were the point
we'd all just stop talking to each other
completely we become like
monks monks with a vow of silence
which increasingly i'm starting to
believe would be perhaps the best
solution for
a lot of problems in our society but for
now
in any case uh the ap is
canceled again and that'll do it for
today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
dailywire2020
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that
and much more see you there
you